oh hell no why are you doing me like
that man
yo gq we're shaking it's your boy asap
rocky here the prettiest [ __ ]
alive
and i'm about to tell you about my style
what are you thinking when you see this
why does it make you laugh like a
[ __ ]
idiot but it was dope for back then nah
that's cool
my first reaction to this is like the
blueprint for a lot of them all
in this era i'm wearing pyrex shorts
pyrex
socks been doing the long socks hood by
hair
t-shirt long sleeve started that white
snap back
white air force ones this is dope
because all that pyrex
i have on was free burger gave it to me
this is before he changed his brand
name to off-white at that moment bran's
like hood by a and ben trail and all of
that was popping off so i kind of like
merged all that together and i think
that was the start of like
street goth or whatever they called it
back then
berger had to change pyrex because of
cesar desis like i think the beaker
company pyrex
kind of you know was coming for that ass
so he had to do the wise thing
and he consulted with us and was asking
some opinions
and subsequently now everybody's walking
around with off-white i actually do
still have those spirit species
somewhere in my mom's house i got a
bunch of [ __ ] at my mom's house
some people who got just spoiled in a
wardrobe my mother has most of my
the air force ones like uh you were one
of the first people to start rocking the
mid tops
how do you know that wow yeah
nobody knows that some people know that
gq knows it to make it clear i just want
to say when we came out
air force ones was dead especially
mid-tops but we brought the uptowns back
because
that was just a hauling thing i guess we
were one of the first to start
rocking mid-tops for however beautiful
all right
that i was the first [ __ ]
rocking air force ones in
2010 and 11 and 12 and all of
that modest would you wear this now
i might i might wear that now depending
on i don't know
so much logos it's too much monograms
damn i'm rocking air force ones again
white air force ones
some cream lawn john thermal pants
red pyrex shorts for red pyrex hoodie
same error
same tour same bad ass pictures
but this look you you kind of started
this look and everyone started looking
like this
that's true and that's why i hate it so
much i have to change it up once once it
gets
outdated you know and it's old if it's
old it's old but if it's in style and
people are doing it i mean that's what
i'm here for we here we all here to like
pick up style tips from each other
inspired so yo
what in the what then we was young as
hell i do remember this day this is asap
ferg's release
i have on a supreme flannel a calvin
klein white t-shirt
a white snap back ironically cut up blue
nudie denims i made them in the shorts
and of course my classic
number one air jordans someone told me
you only wore
ones and fours when you're growing up
yeah what the how do you whoa
you want some narwash how you know this
we did some research
yeah this is true whoa well so people
know that damn i appreciate you for
knowing
thanks man for sure i gotta i gotta say
i got a
co-worker named jeremy he's from harlem
he helped me out with this
yo shout out is jeremy from harlem man
all day
yeah coming up like early in my career
you can only catch me in like
number one jordans or number four
jordans that's the only ones we wore
we didn't win nothing else that's how
you knew that was some uptown harlem
asap
like it feels like now those are the
most too popular jordans
if you ask me how come you haven't done
a nike collaboration yet
because nike sucks damn i'm just joking
i think it's like a a battle between
puma nike adidas and converse cause the
truth is i want to do all four i want to
do a sneaker for every brand
unfortunately i think that it won't work
with me and nike because they usually
make you
do certain and i would go in with intent
behind which one i wanted to design
specifically opposed to being told which
one you could you know curate or design
is it actually designing when it's
already an
established sneaker choosing colors is
that designing
i don't know it's like when you choose
the color for your tesla and the
interior exterior are you designing a
tesla
that's my you get what i'm saying yeah i
went to under armour i went to
ideas i went to different places you
know how they are
but i think that's already been done now
yeah you know i got a pair of vans
coming out they're the best bands i've
ever worn slip-ons
on the game i should have worn them
today shout outs to asap yams that's me
and mama yams on the red carpet for
the grammys 2016. very futuristic
gucci denim jeans adidas stan smith rav
simmons
white gucci t-shirt gucci cardigan black
celine glasses
and goyard satchel i body that
yeah i would wear this again i had got
nominated for the best
music video award for lsd and that was a
song that i created for the album while
yams was still alive so i just felt like
beings that i couldn't bring games to
the grammys
i was gonna bring his mom with me you
know but i knew i wasn't gonna win [ __ ]
i just came dip i s show face got the
[ __ ] up out of it
pharrell lupe fiasco and nego
who i saw went go yard when i was the
kid growing up
and nobody kind of wore it a few times i
saw kanye but
nobody really was into it by the time i
got older pharrell was into like moy not
and everybody was just went lv so i
preferred to win
goldyard because i felt like it was a
luxury brand that
i always wanted to wear but i just never
could afford so by the time i got a
little bit of money i just figured you
know i'll get the [ __ ] i want
and here you have it
see i don't even remember when i flexed
that i think that's a supreme camo
suit i don't even remember what kind of
bucket hat that is but that
fendi three-piece clutch
is amazing i'm just staring at the fendi
right now
you still have that of course i still i
have everything that you see me with
is the camo a little bit of a dip set
inspiration
absolutely to be real it was because i
was performing with yg
you know he wanted to wear all red camo
because he blood gang and all that so
you know he was on his power route i was
like i would go with the brothers
but damn you right this is a killer
outfit
yeah get them girls i derive from with
harlem and with dip set left off that's
what that's what asap derived from so
it was just like just flies like pink
diamonds and [ __ ] pink furs pink range
rovers
badass women you know to be able to like
feel that confident wearing something
that would be considered
a feminine color to show masculinity to
me
and then just show like really like have
individual style
get off without having to look like
everybody and do daring [ __ ] so that's
why i wear pearls and pink and [ __ ]
harlem you know what i'm saying
[Music]
oh man this is one of the worst outfits
i ever wore
that was just off man are you seeing
this
come see this look how whack this
[ __ ] outfit is
i mean i don't really think there's
nothing wrong with gucci head to toe but
when you've got the monogram and the gg
all everywhere you just look tack y'all
i ain't gonna lie i look like i'm on my
way to the atm to scam some [ __ ]
real quick i'm about to go bust a check
one time i don't like this outfit like
that i was on my way to the show
they gave me a few options and i was in
milan and
this is what i came up with i wasn't
working with my own stuff at all but
usually i got a better selection to pick
from this is one of those outfits that i
dread
next i that's a fly photo because she
look fire right there
she looks sexy as [ __ ] i love her bro
that's your favorite outfit of hers
right
i remember that yeah you know what she
might have wore
way better stuff as just i was there in
person to see
honor she designed my my tuxedo that's a
fenty tuxedo with the rick owens
shoes on but nah she designed it i was
all fenty that day
i feel like it made me look very heavy
[ __ ] i look diesel in it you know
i like the 40s gangster yeah [ __ ] with
the oversized look
a random day in harlem fat five freddy
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] that but dan what more can i say
i never thought that i would be
photographed in a photo with fat five
freddie and david then
at the same time in my lifetime i'm
truly blessed
you know i made that jacket i have on
it's all smiles jacket
letterman varsity that's a
midnight rave sex pistol collab
hoodie needles denim jeans and some
very rare exclusive number one jordans
in an old school jacob watch
i always wanted a jacob watch that's
vintage i think the colors that popped
its primary colors i think that helps
it's attractive
like i don't know google or something
like that aside from that
all my favorite rappers from fabulous
cameron puff daddy had one so i wanted
one
oh shh i'm not super i like those pens
necks you want to talk about dior at all
or anything you know about
my deal history i mean a little i'd like
to hear you talk about it
i was the first black male model sign of
dior
and i'm very proud of that fun fact
rihanna was the first
black female sign of dior i don't know
why i just said that but i did
next faux fur dior jacket
mr christian dior himself on my shirt
dior
suspenders and i have air force ones on
under
v-long collaboration and all of this was
designed by christian
ash 2017. not one of my best outfits but
you know we pulled it together
i don't agree with the socks in this
photo i shouldn't have did
the white socks with those i should have
did some other kind of socks
i like the cut it's just those aren't
the right socks and shoes for them i'll
definitely do some hard bottom shoes man
nice shoes and perhaps black socks or
different type of dress socks oh hell no
why are you doing me like that man
i'm sorry yeah we need the good with the
bad the wabi-sabi
v-lone paulie air force one
exclusives a vintage t-shirt
a capital satchel and gucci goggles i
was geeking
coachella that day i mean we was in the
desert so
all that sand and dust and [ __ ] so
that's why i had the goggles on
when you got a bag on stage what's in it
all my [ __ ]
all the weed all the i guess jewelry
wallet more weed yeah like that
and how do you feel about tyler and his
style evolution his whole outfit is
trashing it that's why i'm like damn you
gotta go to the next one my boy
definitely look like he work at i don't
know
i ain't gonna lie that's that's not one
that's not one of our benefits
i'm quite sure that he would concur ah
i love the pins here it's so gucci
everything
those pants are missing from my closet i
don't know where they are but they were
very expensive
and they gave them to me for free 99
which is my favorite price
i wonder who has my gucci pants how do
you lose pants i can see losing
everything
i don't lose it i just got friends and
people who still i steal from them too
so it's okay
we all steal pieces from each other wow
testing error so on the left we have
a test and boiler jumpsuit designed by
paulie
hi mom i'm dead with some classic retro
one jordans
and on the other side we have the same
sneakers but customized
prada tour outfit designed by myself
i was so proud of this well i had the
pleasure of meeting mrs
prada she was lit she was very down to
earth
and she actually gets where you know
fashion culture is shaping and moving
forward towards she's like a catalyst
for that
in my opinion i think the mask that's my
like real slip knot
moment you know i had a little test
dummy face
you know i was trying to prove a point i
just feel like life is just like
it's almost like buffering right or
rendering this is testing
you know i'm experimenting seeing what
works
i'm always finding myself in the pioneer
seat like it's just always testing the
waters man
i have on all the weather i love this
photo because those nails were creative
yeah it was a conversation starter it
just worked out that way
because i was like this at first and i
just was like that
oh [ __ ] works both ways you know my dad
told me
girls don't like men with dirty nails
from that point
i just always he he always had a
manicure on a pedicure so by the time i
was like
15 and 16 i was getting manicures and
pedicures the nail art thing probably
started my late 20s they always
disassociate this
you know with being macho and i think
seeing
men push boundaries especially straight
men i'm all for it
you know with that i think it's
beautiful especially in something like
fashion it's just like it's no
boundaries you know do what the [ __ ] you
want what feels right
fashion is a statement i actually
dressed myself
for this raft show and i took my
balenciaga jacket
to my friend in london when i was living
in london and it was a female's
jacket and it had a long scarf connected
to it
i told them to take the scarf make the
arms longer make a
longer layer and make me a satchel they
made the satchel out of the scarf and
the jacket that's great and those are
proud of ski pants
that's a vintage calvin ski fleece
that i have on because i was on my way
to a raft calvin
show and those are exclusive high-top
nike v-lone air force ones
that never came out barry gillespie
actually i stole them when i was
at one of the stores i just stole them i
was like i'm taking these
damn what i'm big be long like come on
man
are you gonna tell me no no it was all
love he actually made them for me
so man i [ __ ]
hate that this is one of okay
rihanna like dragged you for this outfit
do you remember that
i saw it this is a bad one so i
basically call myself being casual
i have on black acne denims
a rap button up hermes black skill hat
and
those are called mr hair shoes
that was a terrible outfit for them i
wasn't prepared
bt it was i was not prepared first ever
red carpet it's just my outfit where i
was wearing on stage was so much
better i should have just wore the same
thing throughout the day except [ __ ] it
take no risk
i love this this is a levee look from
the clive davis grammy party
the salmon pink some adidas stan smith's
i think it's classy it shows edge and
maturity in my style
i [ __ ] with that [ __ ] always got the
pearls man
very necessary this is like probably my
favorite look on here
word oh yeah are you serious damn thanks
bro
it kind of gives me scarface vibes i was
lit this day enjoying myself
at the met gallery i'm dressed in rash
calvin head to toe
how do you feel about rap i love raf man
what you mean that's a trick question
that's my og man i love rav
damn i wear jordan ones a lot v-lone
yams day
t-shirt collaboration all needles
track pant collaboration union jordan
number one collaboration yams day 2019
yellow bandana i was lit yams day is a
memorial concert that we throw every
year for
late great asap games rest in peace this
is
at barclays center sold out show amazing
hopefully the world will be open next
year and we'll have another concert you
know
it's gonna be sick oh yeah i think
that's uh it's our last one
that was tight it was tight that was a
lot of fun that was fun i can't lie it
was entertaining
maybe we could do another one there's so
many more why not you know how hard it
was for us to
to narrow it down yo but you picked some
horrendous looking outfits man
the worst outfit i had on and and that
was the red carpet
for the bet awards all right what's your
favorite though
can you skim through them yeah yeah of
course this one yeah i mean that's my
favorite
yeah the levee yeah lueve it's too many
fits for us to decide
so it's only right we do another one we
gotta do another one it's not enough to
cram into this
yeah i gotta promise me we're gonna do a
part two yeah i gotta come with some
better selections